(soft techno music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show.
The number one podcast for growing
and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell
and we're from Think Media.
And if this is your first time listening,
welcome.
- This show's dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed
and the latest moneymaking strategies
working right now online.
So, whether you want to
grow you YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
Should every business
have a YouTube channel?
What do you think?
It's a great question, and I think that,
I basically, first, think every business
should have a YouTube channel.
Now maybe one exception is like,
if you have an underground
coal mining company
of some sort or you're doing something
hyper niche, and even still I think that
you could definitely
have a YouTube channel,
but it might not correlate
directly to YouTube,
like that'd make a great reality show,
like behind the scenes.
But beyond that I think that
it really probably comes down to this,
why wouldn't you establish your
presence as a business owner
on the number one video
site on the internet,
the number two largest
website in the world,
and then number two largest
search engine in the world
called YouTube which is a free platform.
And the only thing standing between
you and sharing your
content with the world
and reaching more people and
growing your business bigger
is just taking action and
learning how to use it
and we've seen a lot of
people in our community
that are more traditional
business owners leverage YouTube.
- Yeah, and what about,
does that matter if you're
a local business or if you
have an online business,
does it matter?
- Yeah, it mean I think
that it makes a lot of sense
if you're online and maybe
if you have a global audience
of some kind, you ship
products around the world,
but even for local there's
even more opportunity,
because local search on
YouTube is even easier,
you can do YouTube
advertising as we get into
some of the different
tips, but there's also
a lot of people that are having
a two level approach, one
is, well if you have a
YouTube channel, is it
gonna cause people locally
to enter my place of business?
Maybe not in the short term,
but I think we need to be
thinking bigger as business owners,
be thinking global in
terms of our influence,
like why wouldn't you, even
if you live in a small town,
why wouldn't you want to
become the known, local bakery
or local doughnut shop in your small town,
while at the same time
potentially doing doughnut recipes
and doughnut tutorials that can make you
extra money online, or you
can start shipping doughnuts,
or you can start shipping recipe books,
or even educational
courses about how to build
a local doughnut shop, so it's actually
potentially the conversation
of should you be on YouTube
is the conversation of
catching a bigger vision
for bigger profits, bigger impact,
having really a just maybe bigger mission,
leveraging the opportunity of the internet
and a platform that allows you
to reach people around the world.
- Yeah, and it reminds me of Roger,
tell us a little about Roger.
- Yeah, so I think about
Roger, lives in Dallas,
Roger Wakefield, his
YouTube channel is called
The Expert Plumber, and he's been building
his company for years,
it's now a seven figure plumbing business,
so he's got a team, he's
serving people all over Dallas,
but what he started to realize was that
he was paying a marketing
company a bunch of money,
and they just weren't getting any results,
he was just paying them
to just burn his money
and build his business
because of word of mouth,
and not even related to their efforts,
and he started to attend conferences like
Social Media Marketing
World, and VidSummit
and these types of YouTube
marketing conferences,
and realized, man, this is the future.
So he started to take his business online
and doing plumbing tutorials,
now here's actually the thing,
it really isn't a strategy that correlates
directly to his business,
it's one that just
builds his brand bigger, kind
of gives him the opportunity
to potentially coach other
plumbers and build his brand
in that way to open up
different revenue streams,
but he was able to fire
his marketing company
and business has not gone down
because of the local impact
in Dallas and his business,
but now it's going to another level
where he's thinking about
actually hosting a conference
in a year or two for
residential service providers
about how to enter into
this digital marketing age.
So local plumber sees the
opportunity to jump on YouTube,
it doesn't cost him any money
besides the sweat equity
and potentially team members
that he's devoting to it,
but the platform itself is free,
and the only barrier
to entry is the hustle
he wanted to put in,
and actually by the way
he saved money because he
let his marketing company go
for a couple thousand a month
to actually leverage YouTube
for his plumbing business.
- That is insane, a plumber,
you don't even think
about traditional businesses being able
to use these platforms,
but I know you speak to
customers all day every day
about this being an option
to be able to market your business,
to be able to put your
message out in the world.
He's not helping just plumbers, right?
He's helping normal,
every day people learn
how to do plumbing.
- And it's kind of a new
school way of thinking
because he's also, it would seem,
making himself lose business
because he's giving away free information
that a lot of people
were maybe hiring for.
And his attitude is like,
look, if that person
can just go buy a $10 part
at Lowe's or Home Depot
and fix this themselves,
just because they watch
one of my free videos,
I just want to add back
goodwill in the world, which you think
is why I might have lost
an $80 job or $160 job
by that person not calling me,
but actually the reverse
ends up being true,
now he has goodwill with that person,
so they look up what he's doing online,
they recommend him to somebody else,
so it's actually leading to more business
than he could handle by
actually being more generous,
giving away free information,
kind of moving the free line,
it makes me think of our friend Steve,
he's been a part of our
video (mumbles) academy,
he's a real estate agent,
he's about to have an event
in Arizona that's packed out,
he's bringing people together,
and he's used YouTube
and also Facebook video
and online video period
to grow his business
and sell more homes or
get people's homes listed,
or help people find homes.
And I think about McCann Dogs,
they have a local dog
training business in Canada,
I think around 70 employees.
- Mhmmm.
- But they started to take
some of their dog training information
and put it online, and
put it in digital courses,
creating a whole nother
income stream of revenue
for their business, while
also putting out free videos
to help people with their dog training.
Mike and Kathryn from
Stone Coat Countertops.
- Mhmmm.
Epoxy counter tops, and they
have like 20 income streams
with how they've built this out.
So I think there's definitely
some practical tips
we can get into, but
the bottom line is yes,
if you're in business in 2020 and beyond,
you need to be using YouTube
and thinking different,
and really thinking bigger about
the landscape of the world,
because the internet
has connected all of us,
and things have changed, we're
living through a revolution
so it's time to jump on the bus.
- Yeah, and we've got five tips for
the business owners watching right now,
let's jump into tip number one
which is establish your presence.
- Yeah, I think that
number one, kind of levels
of using YouTube for business
is, if you were to do
anything at all, at
least set up a channel.
At least upload a few videos
so people could find you there
and you could actually be
there, we mentioned it's the
number one video site in the
world, the second largest
website in the world, owned by Google,
Google is the most used
website, YouTube is the second
most used website in the world,
and it's the second largest
search engine which is huge,
there's something around
60% of people right now go
to YouTube asking questions,
so you need to be there,
I think it's irresponsible
as a business owner, again,
unless you're a coal miner
and you live in some
obscure part of the world
with no electricity in
some way, and it's like,
yeah business is fine because
it's all done back channel
through telegraph.
- (laughs)
- I mean, if you're in any
kind of modern business
in a modern connected
way, you just want to be
on the internet and YouTube
is one of those platforms
you should have a few videos up
and your channel optimized,
just so people can find you
and see that you're relevant
in the current century we're living in.
- So important.
So once a business owner gets online,
I know the next question
always is what type of videos
should I make then?
Because as business owners,
we think we need to be
making these big, extravagant videos
talking all about ourselves,
but that's actually not it.
What type of videos should
business owners make?
- Yeah, so it's funny, and that's actually
the mistake that Roger made at first.
So the first 10 videos he did,
which didn't do anything for his business,
was just videos about himself.
- Yeah.
- And it's kind of a thing you think,
okay, people are gonna wanna
know more about my business,
nah, not really, or they're
just gonna want to see
this local clip of me in the media
trying to build my authority, nope,
they don't care about that either.
- Yeah.
- They actually care about their problems,
they care about what it is
that they're dealing with
in that exact moment,
so here's what you do
as a business owner,
what are your top FAQ's?
- Mmhmm.
- Most business owners know
that they have an FAQ website
on their website, because you get
frequently asked questions.
How do I clean my pool?
What is the PH level or whatever
in the pool of the chemicals
that should be there?
What happens if this, you
know, if it's turning green?
All these different--
What are the most asked
questions, turn one question
into one video and upload
that on your website.
Now here's what's cool about that is,
even if you don't think
globally yet or bigger picture,
you are now basically documenting yourself
asking a question that
you can send one to one
in a customer service
way, so eventually you're
listening on Twitter and someone says,
hey, I'm thinking about
I wanna clean my pool
but I'm wondering about this.
Boom, send them a YouTube link.
- Mhmmm.
Somebody sends you an
E-mail and they're like,
yeah I was kind of
curious about this thing,
what do you think?
Oh I explain it here, boom,
send them a YouTube link.
So instead of necessarily
jumping on the phone
which is still something we
should do as business owners,
it could be a great
way to lead a business,
but you're essentially scaling yourself,
why not document you, the key leader,
or someone in your team that can
communicate for your business,
answering the question
that you have to get on the
phone and spend 10 minutes
every day, five times a day,
that's 50 minutes every day,
take that 10 minutes, record a
video, and now just send that
to five people and have your
personal assistant do that,
or somebody else do that
for you, you're already
multiplying your team.
The deeper level of that
is that when you do put out
frequently asked questions,
because people are using
YouTube as a search engine,
it can start bringing you
exposure and awareness to
people around the world
that could benefit from those questions,
like if you help people
prepare their taxes
and you're a CPA or an accountant,
you might just help them
with general preparedness
or general updates
about tax information.
Your thing is, well wait a minute,
what if they never work with me?
Well, all you're doing is adding
more goodwill in the world,
maybe you already have
enough customers and clients,
but people are starting
to fall in love with you
from around the world, and
we've seen friends of ours
like we just had Mitch come
into our inner circle program
teaching about all the
stuff that we need to know
as YouTube influencers
and as people that are
putting content online to stay safe
with social media content,
and he's done a book,
it has led to clients,
he's a local California
attorney and lawyer.
- Right.
- But it's led to him
speaking at conferences
in other states, it's kicked open doors
when he just started giving
away free, valuable information
that's essentially valuable
to people locally for him,
it expanded his whole world
even nationally and globally
because he took action and started posting
frequently asked questions on YouTube.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference,
Grow With Video Live, a $1500 value.
All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple Podcast,
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
- Yeah, it makes me think
of Dr. iHealth also,
he's a doctor in Minnesota or Wisconsin
and he just started
answering those questions
about these contact lenses
or these contact lenses?
And what is this type of eye thing,
and what is this type of eye thing?
I don't know eye doctor terminology,
but he told us that he is
going to be speaking on a stage
for eye doctors of how to use this
to grow their local business.
So I mean, this is, like you
said, this is so impactful
not just for where you are now,
but where the possibility
can go once you get there.
And the possibility can be
endless once you start putting
that information out online.
- And Dr. iHealth, he's
at 80,000 subscribers now.
- Yeah.
- And so he not only still has his day job
of serving people as an eye
doctor, but he's also now
making hundreds if not
a couple thousand dollars a month extra.
- Mhmmm.
- So I don't know if
that sounds interesting
to people watching, but it's
like, you start thinking about
having extra income
stream that could either
go straight towards your future
and retirement or your family,
or it could go back into
scaling your business,
because you might also ask,
well how am I gonna do all this?
This might take a budget.
This could be self
liquidating pretty quick...
- Mhmmm.
When you start applying
some of these strategies
because you can reinvest
those dollars to scale
the media and marketing of your company
with the money you can earn
from some of these strategies.
- Yeah, so now we know
that as business owners
we need to be online, we know that we
need to be answering questions,
you have a strategy on
questions, what type of questions
should we be answering?
- Yeah, I mean the questions should be
usually basic at first.
- Yeah, so simple.
- Simple questions, yeah.
We actually have a
framework, I think we call it
stupid specific starter questions.
- Yeah.
And so they should almost
be like that seems obvious,
well it seems obvious to
you, you're an expert,
you've been baking cookies for 25 years.
- Mhmmm.
But someone starting out, they're like
I just don't know why the
chocolate always comes out hard
and not gooey, and you're
like oh that's because
you didn't use the right--
these are the type of
things that people are like,
now they're perfect
and now...
- Yep.
At the party everybody loves me because
the chocolate chips are perfect.
And now someone like,
you're in their heart,
you've created goodwill
because you just gave them
some free information,
and now maybe they start
having you ship them cookies
or they want to buy your recipe.
It can lead to so much by answering those
practical questions for people.
- Yeah, so now how do
we discover on YouTube
what type of videos, so we
know those are the questions
but how do we know beyond that?
What type of searching should we do?
- Well yeah I think then
the third reason why
businesses need to be on YouTube
is for the SEO value.
- Yeah.
- And we mentioned that
kind of in number two.
YouTube is the second
largest search engine
and SEO means search engine optimization.
When we talk about YouTube
we're talking about
video SEO, video search
engine optimization.
- Mhmmm.
- And so when you're a business
owner, getting new costumers
and getting discovered
by your target audience
is everything.
- Mhmmm.
- And getting your--
if you think about this, what's
it worth to a business owner
to be the first ranking
on page one of Google?
Invaluable.
Well, it's easier to rank
on the first page of YouTube
and there's been reports
from Sisco and others that
when you create video content
it's even easier to rank
videos on the first page
of Google than it is
text websites or just text posts.
So simply by answering specific questions
you're gonna get that
SEO benefit over time
by building that library of videos.
And then you're also gonna get
local SEO, it's even easier.
In fact, years ago in
2009 I had a business,
Clear Vision Media, I was
a free lance videographer,
and I was shooting weddings, concerts,
all this kind of random stuff,
local Seattle hip hop artists,
music videos for them,
and I was also doing websites
for churches and social
medial, kind of just a
one man, I was just doing
it all and helping people
optimize their YouTube
channels, and I did a video
for a local Mexican
restaurant in our small town.
To this day that video still ranks
for Marysville Washington
Mexican restaurant.
And they only paid me a few
hundred dollars to do this.
So you think about the power
of getting this video made,
this video has ranked for eight years.
Now it only has a few thousand views,
but you only made it once, they
hired me to do it one time,
get this video on YouTube
for them optimized,
and now they're the dominate
force in a small town
because of local search
engine optimization,
that video could be
embedded on their website
and they're getting value,
so when you invest in
video assets, I feel like
it's like a fine wine,
it gets better with age.
- Mhmmm.
- You put these videos out...
But then over time
you're still getting
that benefit from them,
or like real estate
they increase in value,
video estate it increases
in value over time.
So the SEO benefits are another reason
that business owners need to
absolutely be using YouTube.
- Yeah, and then let's talk
about YouTube paid advertising.
- Yeah I mean that's
something that I'm sure
you have thoughts on as well.
I think that YouTube
paid advertising is the
other new opportunity for business owners,
even if you never get into a place where
we're not gonna be YouTubers,
we're not gonna have a weekly show,
you can, just like you'd
invest in a billboard,
or in the yellow pages, or in
any other form of marketing,
getting into a direct mail
piece or a coupon book,
whatever, you can pay money
to get in front of your
ideal costumers with YouTube.
In a zip code, in a
certain zip code range,
around what kind of videos are
watching in a zip code range,
so for local, or for anybody
that, especially online,
that maybe want to sell
some sort of a product
or coaching or service to
anybody around the world,
hyper targeting on the
type of videos they watch
or what they follow, or
even search based intent
that can start on Google
and follow them all the way
to YouTube, and this
can be very affordable.
Not only that, the fact that we're
talking about this right now,
I just got off the phone
with a good friend of mine,
I'm about to speak at his
conference this coming weekend,
and he's like, bro Facebook
is like sketch right now,
he goes, I just have had
add accounts shut down,
I've had to have three
appeals, I'm worried because
I'm kind of a one trick
pony in my marketing,
relying so much on Facebook
marketing which is so popular,
and Facebook ads, it's
not like that's dead
and that's still something to leverage,
but YouTube is largely
an untapped landscape
and it can be very affordable
and just something to learn,
it's through the Google Adwords platform.
- Mhmmm.
- And I don't know what
are your thoughts on
YouTube advertising for business
going into 2020 and beyond?
- Yeah, I think it's
something, like you said,
it's a growing thing that
needs to be happening
because there is so
much opportunity there.
When you think about what you're spending
in your marketing budget,
being able to advertise
knowing exactly where your
audience is, is priceless.
And for such a low
cost, and like you said,
you can target by interest,
you can target by videos
watched, you really have
a lot of the same targeting abilities
that you had on Facebook,
and just transferring that
over to a platform where people
are spending a lot of time.
And you can get it right in front of them
before they even start
watching other videos
and have a grace period
where you don't even pay.
They actually get to watch
some of your video first,
your ad first, and if they click past that
you don't pay, but you
still got to have that,
you still had the reference with them.
So I think local businesses having YouTube
is a critical thing coming into 2020.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- And of course then number five is,
this would be the biggest
vision of why a business
should use YouTube, is
really building a brand,
and becoming a media company.
- Mhmmm.
- And it makes me think
of, probably Stone Coat
is such a good example of this,
as a local countertop
business, Epoxy countertops,
they're sourcing those
products and then they're doing
installs for people,
they're making designs,
they're building the kitchen countertops,
custom countertops with the
Epoxy so it's more affordable
and looks like other type of stone setups,
and then what they do
is they start building
basically a media company
online, they realize,
okay we're gonna take on the identity
of being educators and helping
people learn how to do this,
basically giving our
information away for free,
because there's a lot of
interest and maybe people
that want to DIY, do this themself,
maybe other business owners
that want to learn from us,
and see, this is a
different mind set because
that's when business owners are like,
well wait a minute, what
if they steal my secrets,
and it's like, yo, it's 2020 yo.
- (laughs)
- These secrets are everywhere,
they're all on the internet,
it's about putting them into
play, like taking action.
And so they started putting
that out, but what they've done
is not only do they put
out multiple videos a week,
they kind of have different--
it's almost like, you
think about Fixer Upper
like Chip and Joanna Gaines.
- Mhmmm.
- It's thinking, wait, no
we're gonna be a media company.
We're gonna be kind of
positioning ourselves
as personalities that are
authorities in this space,
and that's what they've done.
On top of that, now they
also sell the products
so people can make it themselves.
- Mhmmm.
- So they have the warehouse,
they've got the Epoxy,
people can buy that,
that's an income stream
for their business.
They actually are getting
so many views on their
YouTube channel, that that's generating
between 50 to 100,000 dollars a month...
- Yeah.
In revenue just from YouTube views,
and so then they've got that.
They've still got the
business where you can
actually go do installs for people,
and they've got the team working on that,
they turn it into an
event that people could go
and attend to as well,
and then they've got
even other ways to make money around that
in terms of education.
So they are a media company
that has a lot of things
going on, that's what
we're actually doing
here at Think Media...
- Yeah.
Is we, some people think,
we'll you put out all
this free information,
Think Marketing, this
show is free information,
yes, but we have opportunities
for people to then
be a part because it's a lot to learn,
navigating this landscape is a challenge,
so that's why we have
a conference called Grow With Video Live
where people can learn
to master online video,
the paid strategies,
the organic strategies,
that's why we've got
digital training products
to help people learn these things,
or the books or the
masterminds, it's just because
it's built around the fact
that we are committing
to creating content, and here's the thing,
I think that every business, every church,
every nonprofit, needs to
be thinking about themselves
as a media company.
More and more than ever
before people are thinking,
companies large and small
are hiring a videographer.
- Mhmmm.
- They're hiring a social media manager
or a social media brand voice,
because it's so important
that you be creating content
on LinkedIn, on Instagram, on YouTube,
across the relevant platforms,
putting out content on Twitter
to get the voice out there
of your business, and this is
not just for sales this year
or in the next two years,
this is for establishing
your brand to have
relevance in 2025, in 2030,
and staying really ahead
of the curve so that
you don't experience what Blockbuster did
when they got wiped out by Netflix.
- Mhmmm.
- Or you don't see the
disruption that the taxi industry
is happening when Uber
and Lyft came along.
It's that same thing that's happening,
content is just kind of
the gateway to relevancy
in culture right now,
and so if you wanna take
your business to that level,
you gotta really build a bigger brand
and be thinking at least
as a media company.
And this doesn't have to be over night,
this might be a mindset
that starts right now
when you're listening to this very episode
of the Think Marketing show,
but over the next few months
and over the next few years you say,
okay, I can start steering
my ship that direction
so that I can catch and ride
this wave of opportunity
that we're living through right now.
- Wow, so powerful, and if
you're a business owner,
and you're ready to get started on YouTube
we have some resources down below,
so like Sean just mentioned,
we have a marketing conference
you can come to, we have
digital online courses
that you can take to
educate yourself, right?
Because that's a big piece of this,
it's not just gonna happen.
You need to do exactly what
you did to start your business,
you need to dive into
understanding this market.
Thanks for checking out this episode,
we hope you got a ton of value,
and if you haven't already, subscribe here
to the Think Marketing show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple podcast.
- As we grow this movement of
purpose driven content
creators, we encourage you
to share it with a friend,
and we'll see you in the next episode.
(soft techno music)